all right today's topic i'm gonna be
honest with you guys
we cover a lot of uh a lot less a lot of
uh political topics
just because it's it's just not
interesting i don't i think
i think maybe it's because it's like
american politics but there's like no
nuance involved anymore in
in political discourse everything is
like my team versus your team and
you guys do this and you guys do that
and black versus white and poor versus
rich and
there's no middle ground for any of this
stuff jubilee middle ground cool
yeah you're stupid
but accurate and then i watch the debate
and i feel like the debate and all the
screaming over each other
it was like a microcosm of what
you watched the highlights oh okay it
was like a microcosm
of what the political landscape looks
like today it looks like twitter
conversations
it's unwatchable to know that these
people are like some of the next
leaders of the free world it's just it's
kind of cringy and embarrassing
to know that that's where the political
landscape is at but honestly
that's what youtube looks like that's
what twitter looks like that's what a
lot of people's conversation looks like
and i feel like um because american
politics are so
polarizing and everything is so camp
versus camp
it just becomes impossible to have
conversation everything is an echo
chamber
you go to right-wing oriented channels
and everything is about how the left is
demon you go to left-wing channels and
you know it's everything's about like
how right-wingers are potatoes and this
and that is
it's just hard to be interested in it
there's nothing really much to learn so
for me uh that's why i don't cover it
anymore it's just
ugh this is exhausting so that's how i
feel about it
at some point it just gets boring it
gets boring to be like antifa did this
and black lives matter did that and the
police union did this and
oh my god don't you see that trump is
the worst and badass they're just like
oh my god this is
just too much we're not going to cover
it all right we're not going to cover
biden's comments we're not going to
cover
trump having covet we're not only
covered up it's done
we're out we're out the game all right
we're not interested
maybe one day we'll see when it's gonna
get interesting again
yeah maybe maybe it's just because it's
elections and they have like
nah it's been like this for months it's
been like this for a month yeah but
because of the elections nah but even
before that i was already getting
drained by all this talk
yeah it's not that's not that's not this
is everything is my team versus your
team it's just like okay well then
why are we talking we already picked a
side
like what are we talking about you don't
want to have this conversation yeah reds
are wrong
right blues are great that's what we
decided so why are we talking
just pick a spokesperson let's just
retweet
why are we talking you think i need 10
different voices to say the same thing
about black lives matter i don't care
just get one it's all the same thing
straight out
her retweets bruh if i know once i'm
sure like
i don't wanna talk about this anymore
i'm just not interested it's just too
much i'm just
meh yeah but that's the thing it's not
like it's hard to take
like whenever and i remember that we had
this conversation
us i was trying to like are we going to
talk about this well
what what are we going to bring to the
table what angle are we going to bring
to the table
and with this that's going on right now
we just can't
we can't bring an angle and after that
watching the
the the people commenting on that it's
like
potatoes over potatoes and it's just
it's just not it's not interesting i
rather
i'd rather review there's more we're
more able to have a different take
and bring something more to the table
watching jubilee videos
and watching uh the cut videos
and watching these kinds of channels
than watching the politics it's just not
interesting
because when we watch those kind of
videos i'm talking about the jubilee
cuts and everything and stuff like that
we is a social study that we're doing
wait wait
wait are you saying
that jubilee created better discourse
than the presidential debate
absolutely that's exactly what the hell
i said
and you know how jubilee is dudu bruh
are you are you complimenting jubilee
right now
no i'm dissing the this is the politics
it's not a compliment to jubilee
aren't you embarrassed
aren't you embarrassed by these
conversations aren't you embarrassed by
the lack of nuance how everyone's
reactionary
aren't you just embarrassed by everyone
just screaming at the top of their lungs
and
you're a libtard and you're a
conservator and oh my god
there's no there's no opinions no fact
just insults
this is why i'm not interested it's just
man so yes i'm checking out
it's easier to bring an
angle to those videos and watching like
a debate of politics
but but if you have a stakes in this
election
right if you feel like your voice needs
to be heard you should be informed
but if you want to opt out i completely
understand why mentally
you're like this is not good for my
mental health because i'll be honest
with you the people i know
who are heavily invested in this
political discourse traditionally tell
them to me
it makes them feel worse after reading
lots of man so
there's always a balance and there's
always a price to pay and i'm not mad at
people who do want to get invested and
want to follow everything because they
want to make an informed vote
do your thing but for me my mental
health
i can't i can't watch most of it because
it's just ugh
it's just true the more i watch the more
i walk i see the schemes
and what they trying to do with it and
uh but you can't talk about none of that
because everything is like
you're trying to bring a point to
someone and they're just gonna yell at
you with some insults they're like you
know what i'm not interested with that
i actually care about what i'm making
you know how easy it would be for us to
make money right now
yeah doing political stuff absolutely
easy cheddar absolutely you know you
don't think
i don't know that if i came out tomorrow
i'm like black lives matter is the
conflict
you don't think i know how much money i
would make right
but i'm not going to do that because i
actually care but some of this stuff
is just ridiculous i can't be making a
video a day and we have maybe
making a video a day yeah true we could
go back to that by doing
garbage garbage content but i don't feel
like it's not
it's not even interesting you know one
thing is that whenever we make a video
you you said that whenever we make a
video people are mad people are happy
as long as i said the truth i could
sleep at night
that's it yeah i don't want to engage in
that because i don't i'm not interested
it's whack it's boring all right we said
we we've been saying
i want to hang myself whenever i see
that okay all right all right no more
depressing talk
so that's that's our thoughts if you
don't send us any more requests
[Music]
you